Bishop Morlino of Madison wrote an
excellent letter about the abuse scandal
and I wanted to read paragraphs of it to
you and then focus in on two sentences
in those two paragraphs but just to give
it the full context this is what it says
in part it says it is time to admit that
there is a homosexual subculture within
the hierarchy of the Catholic Church
that is wreaking great devastation and
the vineyard of the Lord the Church's
teaching is clear that the homosexual
inclination is not in itself sinful but
it is intrinsically disordered in a way
that renders any man stabili afflicted
by it unfit to be a priest and the
decision to act upon the disordered
inclination is a sin so grave that it
cries out to heaven for vengeance
especially when it involves preying upon
the young or the vulnerable such
wickedness should be hated with a
perfect hatred Christian charity itself
demands that we should hate wickedness
just as we love goodness but while
hating the sin we must never hate the
sinner it was called to conversion
penance and renewed communion with
Christ in his church through his
inexhaustible mercy at the same time
however the love and mercy which we are
called to have even for the worst of
sinners does not exclude holding them
accountable for their actions through a
punishment proportionate to the gravity
of their offence in fact a just
punishment is an important work of love
and mercy because while it serves
primarily as retribution for the offence
committed it also offers the guilty
party an opportunity to make expiation
for his sin in this life if you
willingly accept his punishment thus
sparing him worse punishment in the life
to come
motivated therefore by love and concern
for Souls I stand with those calling for
justice to be done upon the guilty now
the most notable thing is how he calls
out the homosexual subculture in the
church and this is a a subculture that a
lot of people don't want to admit exists
even people outside of the church are
saying oh no it's got nothing to do with
that well you've got people inside the
church in the know who are saying yes
this exists it is directly linked to the
to the to the sex scandals and it's a
big problem so
that's notable but also very notable is
his call to hatred perfect hatred as he
said I think there's a very important
truth
and I think we are as Christians is
modern people in general are repelled by
the idea of hating a call to hatred
really upsets us but that's only because
we have been indoctrinated into the
modern effeminate version of the faith
the version of Christianity that thinks
hatred is an objective evil and it's the
one thing we should always fight against
as Christians the version that says
hatred cannot be of God because God is
love and hatred is loves opposite and of
course it is true that some God is love
but the rest of that equation is
completely wrong it's untrue hatred is
not the opposite of love hatred is
really an element of love hatred is a
part of love a sign of love hatred is
love turned militant hatred is the
ferocious part of love the aggressive
part now there are of course bad forms
of hatred there are a lot of they're not
all not all hatred is bad but not all
hatred is good obviously and but we can
easily tell if it is a good or bad
hatred by looking at what the hatred
militates against
hatred is always opposing something well
let's look at what it's opposing so
hatred of a different race of people is
bad hatred it's a disordered hatred
because it is hatred directed at you at
human beings at individuals but even
this you know hatred is always attached
to love so even this disordered hatred
is attached to a disordered love and the
disordered bad love in this case that is
attached to race racial hatred would be
the disordered enthusiasm that you have
for your own race a a racist person
makes their own race and Idol they
elevate it far above where it belongs
and so other races fall below it and are
hated now on the other hand if a if a
loved one has cancer and you hate the
cancer that hatred is linked to your
love of the person who's being destroyed
by the disease so it's a good hatred
it's a necessary hatred and it would be
a very sick thing and be very weird
strange horrible thing if you didn't
hate the cancer of a person who you love
or or of any person for a personal
example you know I can say that as a
parent I have really come to hate a lot
of the filth on TV and the Internet
I may have disapproved of it before but
now as a parent I hate it when I see
this stuff on TV I really deeply hate it
because of what it can do to my children
and how it can how it can steal their
innocence and so I have a real burning
hatred for it that is attached to my
love of my kids so and we all have that
right we all hopefully most of us love
our kids and so there are there are
things in the world that we see could be
harmful to our children and we hate
those things it's part of being a parent
it's part it's part of loving somebody
love
and I think love is something that
always seeks to embrace its object while
hatred seeks always to annihilate its
object
and so those of us who think that we
should never hate must therefore believe
that there's nothing in the world that
deserves to be annihilated when you hear
people say well we've got to get rid of
all the hatred no more hatred in the
world
I guess they believe that there's
nothing in the world that should be
hated nothing in the world that should
be destroyed but I disagree I think
there's plenty to be annihilated plenty
to be destroyed in the world there are
many ugly terrible awful deadly
revolting things in our world and I
think we should have a raw raging hatred
for all of those things a hatred that
stems from our love of those that we
embrace and those that we want to
protect from those things
and our and most raging hatred of all
should be directed at sin the Bible is
pretty clear on this the Bible speaks
repeatedly of this holy and righteous
hatred and any commands us that doesn't
just allow us but it commands us to have
this kind of hatred in our hearts for
sin and for evil Psalm 97 let those who
love the Lord hate evil proverbs 8:13 to
fear the Lord is to hate evil Romans 12
9 hate what is evil cling to what is
good
proverbs mentions seven things that God
hates himself and in four places in the
Bible and you heard it referenced in
that letter that I read we're told about
sins that are so terrible that they cry
out to heaven for vengeance that's how
bad they are now there's a passage in
Revelation that I think is really
interesting it says I know your deeds
your hard work and your perseverance I
know that you cannot tolerate wicked
people yet I hold this against you you
have forsaken the love you had it first
consider how far you have fallen repent
and do the things you did it first if
you do not repent I will come to you and
remove your lampstand from its place but
you have this in your favor
you hate the practice practices of the
Nicolaitans which I also hate so
this is what makes it interesting is it
God is talking to the church in Ephesus
and he can find very few redeeming
qualities about them except for their
hatred and their intolerance those are
the two things he cites positively those
are the two good things when he's
indicted them for the bad things he says
well but at least you have correct
hatred and you're intolerant of
wickedness so that you got going for you
if we tend to look at those as that
whether those are the two things you
hatred in and those are the worst thing
in this case God is saying those are the
two best things about you because we
understand that they are ordered
correctly they're directed in the right
direction so they're good and they are
the redeeming qualities you after you
have to wonder what redeeming qualities
will God find in the church in America
because we've also forsaken we
we have also forsaken the love we had at
first but but neither do we have this
hatred for wickedness and there's
intolerance of wickedness so we have
none of that going for us and we tend to
believe that well
yeah we've got all this bad stuff but at
least we're so tolerant we are such a
tolerant Church now here we were we were
so tolerant as Christians and and and so
maybe all the bad stuff will be
overlooked because of our tolerance but
the opposite is the case our tolerance
will not compensate for the other sins
because our tolerance is one of our
greatest sins tolerance is never
commanded in the Bible because it's not
a virtue it's a false virtue
we should be running hot and cold as
revelation said we should we should love
and we should hate
and these things should be properly
ordered and properly directed the only
things that we should really tolerate
are the things that are morally neutral
and thus we don't need to be told to
tolerate them so I can tolerate for
instance the color of the shirt you're
wearing and I hope you tolerate the
color the shirt that I'm wearing because
it's not pink it's salmon I tolerate the
existence of that tree outside I
tolerate the sky I tolerate the number
seven I tolerate the color blue
I tolerate the grass you know these are
many things that I tolerate because
they're morally neutral they just are it
would be very weird for me to have
negative feelings about them they just
they they exist and so fine they exist
they in themselves they have no moral
substance
but and that's why nobody would ever
tell you well tolerate the grass you
know tolerate that thing over there they
wouldn't tell you that
it's the kind of things
that people feel the need to tell us we
should tolerate
should not be tolerated
people tell us we're told to tolerate
people of other races no we shouldn't
tolerate people of other races we should
love them
people tell us to tolerate opposing
ideas well though we shouldn't tolerate
opposing ideas it really depends on what
the ideas if it's a bad idea if it's a
false idea if it's a harmful idea then
we should reject it we shouldn't just
thought we should simply tolerate it we
should reject it if it's a good idea if
it's true if it's and all that then we
should embrace it I don't think
tolerance really comes into play we're
told to tolerate debauchery and
perversion and sin no we shouldn't
tolerate those things we should hate
them because they're degrading and
harmful and there are defense against
God and against man things that have
some kind of moral significance good or
bad should provoke something in us
stronger than mere tolerance
and if it's a sin than it should provoke
hatred
and it will provoke hatred if we really
love God and if we're truly outraged at
offenses against him now it'll be
stipulated that we should always make
sure it said it said in the letter that
I read we should always make sure to
love the sinner as we hate the sin and
that's obviously a mantra that you hear
repeated quite a bit it's true that we
should make sure that we hate the sin
and we're not hating the sinner we
shouldn't we shouldn't hate human beings
because as I said to hate something is
to want to destroy it annihilate it and
we shouldn't have that feeling about a
human being and I guess I should say
it's more maybe it's more than just
wanting to destroy something it's like
wanting to dam it really wanting to send
it to hell which is what we want to do
with bad things with sins is just damn
them to hell down into the darkness and
we should never have that feeling about
a person because we should always want
people to be saved we should always want
people to even bad people to repent and
go to heaven that's that's the desire we
should have for all people so hate the
sin not the sinner but there really
isn't a conflict here we hate a sinner's
sin because we love him and we love God
the two things are linked so most of the
time it doesn't even make any sense it's
redundant it's pointless the cells tell
someone well make sure you're not ate in
the center well it's uh
if I if I if I hated the center I
wouldn't hate his sin if if I really
hate the sinner then I probably won't
have much urgency
in fact if I really hate the sinner i'll
more likely take pleasure in his sin
because it's destroying him and i hate
him and so i like to see him destroy
think about it think about a time when
you have really hated someone even
though we're not supposed to hate people
many of us have committed that sin i
believe so
if you've ever if you have ever hated
someone before as wrong as it was
did you feel disappointment did you feel
sadness when you heard about the bad
things that they did
if there's been someone say at work who
you hate and
but and then and then someone else comes
up to you and says and says oh well hey
guess what terrible things so-and-so did
do you go no no don't don't tell me I
don't want to be disappointed in them
don't please don't tell me about those
things no you are you're amused you're
delighted by the terrible things they do
that's why people enjoy gossiping about
those they dislike and that's what makes
gossip so vicious and so awful because
it delights insid that's all point of
gossip
nobody gossips about good things if it's
a good thing you're complimenting
someone behind their back then it's not
gossip gossip is always negative things
and it's almost always Oh guess what
so-and-so did just listen to the
terrible things they've done
a hateful conversation it's hateful of
the person and it is delighting in the
bad things that that they did and I
think that's the mistake we make we say
that a gossipy person is judgmental but
that's not true they aren't making
judgments against sin they're loving sin
the problem isn't that they have too
much moral judgment the problem is that
they lack moral judgment entirely
so usually when we really hate someone
we oh we have no Tim we have no
inclination to hate their sin and
usually if we really hate somebody's sin
if we see someone doing something and
it's wrong and we really hate the wrong
thing then that is going to come at
least in part that's going to stem from
our respect and love for that person
because we just hate to see them doing
this thing
and we've all experienced that is what
think about his parents especially I
don't have older kids but especially as
your kids get older and they get to the
age where they can really do really bad
things and they can really hurt you I
think about when you've found out about
your kid doing some really bad thing and
you absolutely hate what they did you
have a real hatred for what they did but
you have no hatred for them whatsoever
your your the intensity of your hatred
for their actions comes from your love
for them because they're so disappointed
and hurt that someone that you love
would do this thing and you wish uuuuu
do anything if you could go back and
erase it so that they never did that
thing right I think the tempt the
temptation to hate the sin and the
sinner together at the same time that
only really arises when the sin is so
terrible and so horrific and our
revulsion against it is so intense that
we just have trouble separating the two
and that does happen
I think with the more minor sins it's
different it's easy to hate a white lie
but not to hate the person who told the
white lie and that's an easy that it's
easy to separate those two things it's
much more difficult I think when it
comes to something like child rape
it is in that case much more difficult
to hate the child rape while loving the
child rapist
because that sin is of a certain nature
and to a certain degree that we the
militant side of our love takes over
that kind of destroying annihilating
offensive protective kind of side of us
and we we simply want to destroy
everything associated with that sin
because this sinner has descended so
deeply into the darkness that we can
barely even recognize his own humanity
and all we want to do is easily like I
said my piece yesterday I wrote on this
is kind of like lob or grenade into that
into that darkness and destroy
everything inside of it that's the
inclination that we have and it's wrong
we should repent of that
you know even with something like child
rape we should detest the sin with the
fire of a thousand suns but we should
not detest the person
although like I said with sins like that
it is really difficult to separate those
two uh and I have not figured out
exactly how to separate them I'll fully
admit that
probably in every case that I've read
about a case like that my first reaction
is just full-on hatred for everything
involved and it's covering everything I
can
I can't target it you know I guess it's
not a targeted hatred and so that's
something I need to repent of and that's
something I need to work on but you know
and I think that's probably case for a
lot of us right
and we should all work on that we should
never just accept the fact that we're
hating another human being no matter how
terrible that human is but I think we
should also be worried
about ourselves if we don't experience
that temptation at all
like when it comes to child rape if you
have no trouble not hating the child
rapist if you have no temptation to even
hate them and it's no problem for you
it's like yeah oh yeah fine I yeah I
don't hate him at all
well that could mean that you are
saintly and spiritually enlightened and
so spiritually mature and and and you
have grown so much that you can easily
separate the two
hate the sin not the sinner it's no
problem for you that could be the case
in which case I admire you but more
likely and I think for most people in
that category it just means that you're
indifferent
that's where it comes from
maybe a more a more more relevant
example is abortion so all
to Christians sometimes about abortion
Christians who are I'm talking about
Christians who would identify nominally
as pro-life they say that it they they
don't support abortion it's bad you know
it's murder so I mean they'll play it
they'll pay it lip service but
when you talk to them it's clear that
they they they have no real anger at all
they don't they don't really feel
anything about it and then they'll go on
and they'll launch into a saying but I
you know I don't like how pro-life or
sometimes they're - they're they're too
hateful and they're they're mean and all
this and they'll start talking about
criticizing the methods that pro-life
and if pro-lifers are too aggressive or
- or too hateful in their approach and
they'll be critical of that they'll say
you know we got to be more reasonable we
need to blah blah blah and a lot of what
they're saying is true but you realize
when you're listening to them it's easy
for them to say that because they have
no hatred at all for abortion they don't
have they don't have hatred for the
people that are getting abortions which
is good but they also have hatred for
abortion they just don't really care
that much they haven't really that they
don't feel much about it and so it's
really easy for them to stand off at a
distance and say oh yeah don't you know
you got to be more bit more civil right
and that's bad
if we have to err it's better to err on
the other side
I think if we have if we have to air
it's better to err on the side of having
too much hatred for really evil things
than not having enough or really any
hatred for it
because when you get on that side now
you're tumbling very close to
indifference and I think indifference is
the most dangerous state for a Christian
or really any person to be in
and it seems like it's very hard to
climb out of indifference
because it's a total lack of its it's a
it is a vacuum there's nothing there you
feel nothing
and I don't what do you do to generate
those feelings of love and hatred and
everything else
the other hand if you look at something
like abortion or child rape and you're
so overcome with anger and fury at this
awful terrible thing and maybe it's a
little overboard because it starts
bleeding into your hating people you
know that's bad
but it's it's better err on that side
because then at least there's something
there to work with you've got the right
general idea I mean you you see this
evil thing and you hate it you hate it
for the right reasons because of what it
does to innocent people and that's all
good and now you through prayer and
discipline you just have to figure how
to target that more and be more and be
more restrained in in your response to
it
I guess my fear is that in our culture
among Christians and people in general
we tend to err much more on the other
side towards indifference
and it's because of that that we have
come to see hatred as this objectively
terrible thing that we should never ever
do because a lot of us are never tempted
towards it because we simply feel
nothing and that's a bad sign all right
I'll leave it there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed